oggi vi racconterò che cosa
per me
la conosce
e soprattutto il paesaggio
nel
nel mio mondo lavorativo il mio mondo
artistico
cerco sempre di andare contro le regole
di creare nuove nuove visioni nuovi
punti di vista e lo faccio soprattutto
confrontandomi con con il paesaggio e la
visione del paesaggio perché negli
ultimi secoli
il paesaggio è sempre stato più
costruito da eventi culturali che
l'hanno arricchito e trasformato infatti
tendenzialmente si si si usa dire che il
paesaggio è una costruzione sociale
proprio costruzione sociale data da da
questi eventi culturali e in parte oggi
ve ne racconterò alcuni e volevo
iniziare chiedendovi di chiudere per
qualche secondo gli occhi e iniziare a
immaginare un fiocco di neve un
cristallo di neve se lo facciamo
veramente tutti insieme ci renderemo
conto che stiamo immaginando uno stesso
una stessa immagine che sono poi queste
immagini che purtroppo o per fortuna a
volte incontriamo spesso durante periodo
natalizio lungo le strade e lungo nelle
nostre case sugli alberi mentale che
sono questi
fiocchi di neve sono stati fotografati
per la prima volta da wilson bentley
questo fotografo americano che ha
passato tutta la sua vita a scattare
foto di fiocchi di neve che cadevano
appena caduti dal cielo è iniziato a a
fare un archivio enorme di questi
cristalli quindi oramai tutti noi li
conosciamo perfettamente questo archivio
compie nei 5000 immagini di friscia gli
unici tra di loro completamente diversi
geometrici non c'è ne uno veramente che
assomiglia all'altro e questa unicità è
diventata ancora più
più interessante per fatto che qualche
anno fa una scienziata americana di nome
nel sinai ha individuato ha scoperto che
in origine i fiocchi di neve alla loro
partenze sono esattamente tutti identici
wii ds e la loro caduta verso verso la
terra che li trasforma e li fa diventare
quello che che noi vediamo questa questa
loro unicità e vi vorrei leggere due
righe di adam koplik un scrittore che io
amo molto che leggo e che mi aiuta a
volte anche ad accendere de per i miei
lavori chi dice la verità ultima sui
fiocchi di neve e che diventano
individualmente più diversi man mano che
scendono maltrattati dal vento e dal
tempo vengono tradotti come per magia in
disegni più strani e complessi sino a
quando finalmente toccano terra
e allora come noi si sciolgono questi
due visionari mi hanno portato a mi
hanno acceso delle la voglia di creare
un archivio di neve personale è cercato
di farlo in modo totalmente diverso un
po con un riferimento fotografico a
wilson bentley è un po cercando una
nuova una nuova esperienza
sono andata quindi paesaggio invernale
mi sono immersa nella neve ho portato
con me delle tele totalmente bianche leo
posizionate come si vedono dalla foto
sul manto nevoso e lo cosparse riscopre
le coperte totalmente di neve e poi lo
colorate o colorato la superficie con un
pigmento spray perché volevo che la
superficie quindi impronta nella neve
rimanesse sul sulla tela questo in
particolare a volte mi piace raccontare
questo lavoro come se ci fosse un legame
stretto con il mondo fotografico forse
mi è venuto in
niente anche perché conosco il mondo
della fotografia winson ben tre era un
fotografo amava con la neve quindi
queste connessioni si sono unite tra di
loro e poi mi piace pensare che la tela
sia un foglio di carta dal foglio di
carta fotografico che la neve sia il
soggetto lo spray che io ho colorato la
neve la luce che colpisce la neve e lo
sciogliersi della neve il tempo di
esposizione che troviamo sempre
nell'ambito fotografico
il risultato di questi lavori sono
queste tele una diversa dall'altra
perché come band ci ha dimostrato che i
fiocchi di neve sono veramente gabbie eu
e diversi tra di loro anche la
superficie quindi anche il fiocco che
poi raggiunge finalmente e dopo questo
lungo viaggio di trasformazioni il manto
nevoso è diverso questi sono su carta i
colori che vedete la variante non ho
voluto banalmente usare il bianco mi
invece sono andata alla ricerca di di
quelle tinte che si trovano nella
profondità dei ghiacciai o poi voluto
fare anche un altro passaggio nei primo
lavoro che avete appena visto o quindi
catturato e ho iniziato un archivio
della superficie della neve e mi sono
chiesto se potevo fare la stessa cosa ma
a livello scultoreo quindi sono andata
sempre in montagna portando mia presso
il materiale necessario veramente
trasferito all'aperto
il mio studio e ho preparato un impasto
che si ma è molto simile al gesso che ho
versato come si vede dall'immagine su
direttamente sulla neve anche il gasolio
o atteso atteso che un minimo con
l'impasto si raffreddasse per poi
prelevare tutto il blocco e portarlo con
me verso verso la valle verso la città
lungo questo percorso ovviamente il la
neve si è sciolta e ha restituito
cito il suo interno quello che conteneva
questa tra l'altro è una delle prime che
ho fatto e ne sono rimasta molto
meravigliata in realtà non sapevo che
cosa sarebbe successo non sapevo nemmeno
se sarei riuscita a farlo ma avevo
questa idea in testa e volevo a tutti i
costi provarci e sono poi rimasta
veramente stupita sia della bellezza
perché alcuni assomigliano dei coralli
15 anche questo legame col colmare con
la neve quindi senza saperlo oggi c'è un
ciclo che continua e sono anche loro
tutti diversi
il titolo di questo progetto si chiama a
futura memoria perché in realtà è anche
non solo un archivio privato in realtà
vorrebbe essere un archivio per le
generazioni future che purtroppo non
vedranno e non toccheranno la neve
perché ci stanno annunciando che molto
probabilmente prima del previsto la neve
scomparirà e queste sculture nella mia
idea potrebbero far parte di una vender
kummer del del futuro quindi se i
blocchi di neve che è stato firmandogli
o prelevati nelle vette delle montagne
qua a diverse altitudine nel nel nostro
in piemonte intorno alle alpi proseguo
il racconto rimanendo sempre in montagna
perché se vi dicevo all'inizio che ci
sono degli eventi culturali che hanno
modificato il modo in cui guardiamo il
paesaggio
un evento molto eclatante è stata la
scoperta della della montagna perché
pensando oggi alla montagna con un luogo
non conosciuto ci sembrerebbe molto
strano però è avvenuto è avvenuta la sua
scoperta prima del settecento
incredibile pensarci ma non veniva
assolutamente vista quindi le persone
non ne avevano bisogno ne avevano paura
e non
non la guardavano e quindi non avevano
nessuna intenzione di rapportarsi con
essa solo è il titolo di questo libro
emblematico perché l'invenzione del
monte bianco di philippe gotthard
racconta proprio come avvenuta
finalmente la visione della montagna
sono stati gli inglesi loro privi di
montagna e raggiungendo le nostre alpi
che finalmente hanno puntato il dito
personale montagne ce li hanno
finalmente mostrate quindi nel mio
lavoro stavo proprio riflettendo sul
fatto che solo dopo il settecento le
montagne sono state avvistate e mi son
chiesta ma annibale che tutti noi
conosciamo che era attraversato le
nostre montagne e stiamo parlando del
200 avanti cristo che cosa vide che qual
era la sua preparazione culturale nel
nel momento in cui stava portando con sé
verso roma un esercito di uomini 27 le
elefanti allora sono andata al passo
delle traver 7 che luogo ormai oggi
stabilito che il passaggio di annibale
perché hanno trovato delle tracce di
sterco di elefante si presume che siano
passati solo gli elefanti di annibale
sono andata quindi su questo passo che
si trova al fianco del monviso siamo ai
2900 metri ho scattato un immagine che
io vedevo in quel momento lì non so
hannibal e quindi ho scattato questa
foto tornata in studio lo stampata
identica sempre lei cinque volte cinque
volte e ho iniziato a immaginarmi le
emozioni di annibale quindi o ne ho
tolto delle parti perché era impossibile
immaginarsi caliber vide nella sua
totalità il paesaggio e questi cinque
interventi sugli interventi di abrasione
direttamente sulla sulla carta
fotografica con la carta vetro quindi
non uso penne
negli altri strumenti prendo proprio la
carta vetro da da falegname con le varie
grammature inizio a cancellare a
smuovere il pigmento della foto per
creare quindi delle emozioni dei
sentimenti forse può essere la più
fedele per annibale e i brandelli anche
di carta che poi esposto tutto quello
che viene tolto dal dalla lavorazione io
non lo elimino quindi è un lavoro dove
la parte tolta e diventa poi la parte
aggiunta del nella mia lavorazione
volevo chiudere la presentazione invece
raccontandovi di quest'ultimo progetto
che ho fatto che è una serie di disegni
che ho fatto ad alta quota portandomi
con me dei plexiglass abbastanza grandi
e quando raggiunto la meta che mi ero
prefissata mi sono seduto ho iniziato a
disegnare ovvero ad incidere con una
punta di grammofono la superficie della
della lastra a disegnare paesaggio ma
non stavo disegnando il paesaggio che
avevo frontalmente a me salvo disegnando
il paesaggio che che aveva alle spalle
perché il plexiglas con un foglio
posizionato nero dietro era diventato
totalmente specchiante e quindi fin
quando c'è stata luce io ho passato
tutta la giornata a
a disegnare i profili dei monti che
avevo alle spalle e si riflettevano
questo
e questi sono i risultati lungo lavoro e
la cosa che sarete sicuramente notando e
che per me è importante è il vuoto che
c'è tra i due disegni e quel vuoto ii e
la mia è la mia presenza
io presente nel paesaggio il mio corpo
la mia formale la mia cultura
vorrei anche dire mi stava impedendo di
osservare nella nella totalità il
paesaggio
stasera infatti l'invito era quello di
fare un passo indietro se l'avessi fatto
forse avrei potuto vedere meglio
l'immagine quindi di fare un passo
indietro e se in un futuro vi capiterà
mai di andare a fare un'escursione in un
paesaggio
potete farlo anche non montano non mi
offendo dovrà mettersi un po i bordi e
iniziare a guardarlo con i propri occhi
e cercando di eliminare tutti gli
stereotipi culturali che lo circondano e
quindi non osservarlo come se fosse la
semplice solita cartolina che che a
volte vediamo in giro
[Applauso]